the rel do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie I need to learn to feel
better when the long night comes again I
need to be ready what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 Theory video before
I get started I just want to let
everyone know the winner of the giveaway
has been randomly selected and that
person's name will be announced at the
end of the video so if you entered the
giveaway make sure you stay until the
end to find out if you've won now let's
get started today I want to talk about
the weirwood tree that's in winter fells
godswood the heart tree that we see in
the godswood has been there for
thousands of years and this has been a
very special place for House Stark
because as we all know they pray to the
old gods where woods are considered
sacred to the followers of the old gods
and the children of the forest even
believe the where woods are the gods the
green seers of the children of the
forest can see through the eyes aware
woods with carved faces since trees have
no sense of time
the green seer can see into the past or
present when looking through the eyes of
a tree the tree that's in winter fells
godswood has even more significance now
because a member of House Stark is a
very powerful green seer who can use
these trees as a weapon some of you may
have seen one of my recent videos where
I read one a brain starts chapters from
a dance with dragons in that chapter we
learned that weirwood trees are the
first thing a green seer is able to use
as their eyes but in time a green seer
can see far beyond the trees themselves
we got a glimpse of this and one of
brands very first chapters which I just
recently read on my channel as well this
is when the three-eyed crow teaches
brain how to fly
this enables bran to see the entire
realm and everyone in it he is able to
see everything from Winterfell all the
way to the lanes of ash I by the shadow
now in the TV show Game of Thrones it
seems to that whenever a green seer uses
the eyes of a weirwood tree the tree
also seems to take on their appearance
when the three-eyed raven was bound to
the tree inside the cave some of the
faces on the weirwood trees had a very
strong resemblance to his own face the
trees almost look just like the
three-eyed Raven whenever he is using
those tree
and we see this again in season seven
when brain stark becomes the new
three-eyed Raven bran is sitting right
next to the tree and if you look at his
face and the face of the tree they
almost look identical especially when it
comes to the facial expressions it seems
to suggest that brain is currently
inhabiting that tree but we know there
is one more character that also has
access to the weirwood net and that is
the night king there is also some
evidence that may suggest the night king
has been looking through the eyes of
Wonderful's weirwood tree ever since
season two if that's true this could
help support so many different theories
which I want to get into today but first
I have to give a shout out to the person
who pointed this out there is another
Game of Thrones and A Song of Ice and
Fire youtuber who goes by the name of
Khaleesi clues I recently saw one of her
videos and in that video she is the one
who actually pointed this out I thought
this was a very interesting observation
because it could support many of the
other ideas I have discussed on my
channel already so that's when I decided
to reach out to her and make sure it was
okay for me to mention the clue if you
would like to see her video on this
topic I will put the link to her video
and channel down below she currently has
about 30 subscribers but I think with
the help of all of you we can get that
number much higher so please go
subscribe to her channel because she
does have some other interesting videos
now let's take a look at the weirwood
tree from season 2 because it has some
striking similarities to the night Kings
face this scene was shortly after Theon
had control of Winterfell at the time
Bray and Rickon Hodor and OSHA were
hiding down in the crypts of Winterfell
but after the castle was burned they
began to flee the area and as they're
leaving they noticed maester Luwin
laying under the tree as he's dying take
a look at the trees face during this
scene and no longer looks like the
three-eyed Raven and it certainly
doesn't look like bran stark not only
does it look like the night king but it
also reminds me of the painting left on
Dragonstone by the children of the
forest now if you listen to the dialogue
in this scene when maester Luwin is
talking to them what he tells them to do
could also relate to the face on the
tree they may come back you have to go
put on your warmest clothes pack as much
food as you can carry and go north north
wrong way we don't know where
and who too many enemies in the south go
to the wall to Jon you'll look after you
and let your mother know you're safe
as you can see maester Luwin tells them
to go north and this starts brain on his
journey that will eventually lead to him
meeting the night king face to face and
if that's the night Kings face in the
tree he has known this the entire time
we know the night keen can access the
weirwood net because we've seen him do
it when brain was also inside of the
weirwood net the night king seemed to
have set a trap for brian because he was
just sitting there waiting for him and
this allowed him to grab bran which gave
him access to the three-eyed Ravens cave
I think it would also support the theory
that the knight King has been planning
things of the whole time
like I've said in some of my other
videos I think the knight king is a
green seer - and this might be why the
children chose to turn him into the
knight King in the first place you see
one of the main reasons why the conflict
between the children and the first men
started was because they were cutting
down their trees and they were even
burning their weirwood trees this made
the children act which resulted in years
and years of bloodshed even though the
children had magic on their side they
were still outnumbered so the children
needed a weapon that could turn the
numbers against the first man out of
desperation they created a weapon that
can raise all of the dead but in order
to do this the children needed to find
someone that had greensight and the
ability to control animals and even
people just like Brian Stark in the
books there is a legend about the
night's king he was the 13th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch and
according to old nan this man was a
stark of Winterfell well one night he
was approached by a woman that was
described as a female white Walker so
they began to have sex and they
eventually got married soon after the
Lord Commander had the ability to bound
his brothers of the Nights Watch to as
well which means he was able to control
them but this story ends in a Cain and
Abel like fashion the night King's
brother just happened to be the stark of
Winterfell and he got word of what his
brother was doing at the wall he was
also put in a desperate situation which
led to him joining forces with the
king-beyond-the-wall
and together they brought down the
night's king and queen it's a very
important legend because it's happening
all over again today in the
story when the children created the
night king they actually tied him to the
weirwood tree because they wanted to
make this weapon as powerful as possible
their weapon needed to be able to access
all of their powers as well I think the
man they captured already possessed some
of their powers like warding at the very
least but after they tied him to the
weirwood tree and shoved dragon glass in
his chest this gave him the power of
greensight and the power to raise the
dead along with creating his own super
soldiers like the White Walkers I also
happen to believe this man comes from
the same bloodline as the Starks and
just like the legend of the night's king
it will take another stark to bring him
down
that's why bran and John have had such a
strong connection with the night king I
think the night king has been using the
weirwood trees just like bran and he
knows that these are the Starks that are
coming to take him down he has been
keeping an eye on them the entire time
dating all the way back to season 2 and
possibly even before that the night King
started to become very active again once
John was about to go to the wall and
brain was about to be visited by the
three-eyed crow in his dreams the night
king knew it was time to start raising
an army because brain and John were
about to be heading his way he let bran
make it all the way to the cave because
he knew he would eventually catch him
inside of the weirwood net once the
three-eyed crow started teaching bran
how to use it
he allowed John to capture a white
because he knew it would lead to him
capturing one of Danny's dragons the
night King knew one of his White's was a
very small price to pay for the life of
a dragon not only does it increase the
knight gains firepower but it also gave
him access to all of Westeros and can
you guess where the night king is
heading next I've been saying it in
video after video he's going after the
only few characters that are even
capable of stopping him and those
characters will all be in Winterfell at
the same damn time they may have even
been hinting at this as the wall came
crashing down when the army of the Dead
were marching through
eastwatch-by-the-sea we got a bird's-eye
view of the night king's army it does
kind of resemble the stark sigil but
whether that was purposely done or not
that doesn't change the fact that the
night king wants to take out his biggest
threats who will be at Winterfell at the
start a next season around 8,000 years
ago the night King had control over the
wall for 13
years until his own brother the stark of
Winterfell and did his reign by killing
him and this is what is about to happen
in the current story stark versus Starks
and I think Ground Zero will take place
right at their home in Winterfell now
when it comes to the weirwood tree in
season two whether that's the night
Kings face or not is up for debate but
it makes so much sense to me because of
the Starks deep word in history with the
others this also supports the theory
that the night king has the power to
look through the trees as well I think
this was proven when he was able to
access brains vision and physically grab
him not to mention he did seem to just
be waiting around for Danny to arrive
with her dragons I think we could come
to find out the night king has been
planning things all along ever since the
beginning of the story but let me know
what you think does any of it make sense
to you or do you have another theory of
your own put your thoughts and questions
down below in the comment section I
would love to hear what you have to say
now it's time to announce who won the a
song of Ice and Fire books said the
website draws the name at random and the
person who was pulled out of the Hat is
John Hannah congratulations John make
sure you send me an email with your
address that way I know where to ship
the books if you did not win today do
not worry I'm starting a new giveaway in
the very next video I want to thank
those of you who participated and I also
want to thank Khaleesi clues please go
and subscribe to her channel and check
out some of her other great videos I
would love to see her subscriber count'
get to over a hundred by the end of the
day anyways thanks for watching the
video I really appreciate that I hope
everyone has a great day I'll see you
again very soon but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you